it's a rational question my cousin is at
the airport she needs the identity card
could you give me a ride yes you can
come thank you so much let's go Gary mad
words for some success yep all right
where am I going try more words for
success root
you're gonna die I did that one so maybe
it's patience now you're young when
you're young all of you guys [ __ ] up
because you want it so bad too soon
I didn't even work 20 hours a day until
I was 30 and didn't talk to anybody
waited thank you you guys wanted today
yes you gotta wait you're not coming are
you continue hundred anyone I'm double
your age like you live a whole nother
[ __ ] life and you're my age and you
want it tomorrow you gotta put in real
work you have to come up with some idea
you think that will work
the knowledge that do you think the
knows that you get it in University will
be helpful in the real world no but if
you want to get a job yeah but not if
you're Bob does the Florence I forgot it
wins rope and it's I'm gonna clean it up
so you gotta be great and I'm gonna do
whatever it takes
giving you my home everyt